>> Tucker: U.S.-MEXICO BORDER
IS EXPERIENCING A FULL-BLOWN
CRISIS ABOUT 100,000 PEOPLE
ARRIVED THERE LAST MONTH ALONE
TRYING TO GET IN HERE AND
CERTAINLY MANY DID.
WHEN REASON FOR THIS CRISIS USE
THE BEHAVIOR OF THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNMENT'S ECONOMY
REALIZED PROFOUNDLY REALIZED
REMITTANCES SENT BACK FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT MEANS INSTEAD OF CARING FOR
OWN POOR, MEXICO CAN UNLOAD ON
US NOT TO MENTION POOR CENTRAL
AMERICA.
DESPITE THIS MEXICO RECEIVED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN DIRECT FOREIGN AID FROM THE
UNITED STATES IN ADDITION TO ALL
THE INDIRECT AID NAFTA HAS
PROVIDED.
IS THERE ANY REASON TO CONTINUE?
THE SECRETARY OF MIGRANTS AND
FOREIGN AFFAIRS FOR MEXICO STATE
AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US MR. HERNANDEZ.
WE THINK OF MEXICO AS AN ALLY.
I GREW UP ON THE MEXICAN BORDER
AND I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT OF
MEXICO AS AN ALLY TO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND I THINK THE PEOPLE ARE
FRIENDLY BUT THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT IS CLEARLY HOSTILE TO
AMERICAN INTEREST.
I WANT TO READ THREE QUOTES FROM
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL IN
THESE ARE DIRECT QUOTES.
WE WERE A BETTING
MEXICAN-AMERICANS WILL THINK
MEXICO FIRST EVEN FOR THE
SEVENTH GENERATION.
MEXICO IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
GOING TO KEEP 1 FOOT IN MEXICO.
THEY WILL NOT DISSEMBLE LATE IN
THE NOT BEING MEXICAN AND FINAL
QUOTE, WE RECOGNIZE THE MEXICAN
POPULATION IS 100 MILLION IN
MEXICO AND 23 MILLION WHO LIVE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THOSE QUOTES ARE FROM YOU.
AND I WONDER IF THE GOVERNMENT
TAKES THAT POSITION, THAT IT'S
HUNTING FOR NATIONAL -- THAT IS
RIGHT.
THAT IS A HOSTILE ACT.
SO WHY ARE WE SENDING MONEY TO A
COUNTRY COMMITTING HOSTILE ACTS?
>> NO, IT'S NOT, MY FRIEND, NO,
NO IT'S NOT A HOSTILE ACT AT
ALL.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS IT?
>> UNITED STATES AND MEXICO ARE
FRIENDS, PARTNERS, NO, I
MENTIONED THAT WAS A BOOK FROM
15 YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: HAS YOUR POSITION
CHANGED?
>> I HOPE I HAVEN'T GOTTEN TOO
OLD EITHER.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR 15 YEARS,
THAT IS TRUE.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION --
>> Tucker: HAS YOUR POSITION
CHANGED?
>> HERE WE ARE 15 YEARS, MAYBE
MORE IN THE SITUATION AT THE
BORDER, MIGRATION, IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IN THE UNITED STATES IS
STILL BROKEN.
I REMEMBER DOZENS OF YEARS AGO
MY FRIEND WE WERE TALKING HOW
THE UNITED STATES, CANADA AND
MEXICO SHOULD WORK TOGETHER AS
THREE INDEPENDENT NATIONS.
I'M NOT PUSHING FOR AN OPENING
BORDERS, BUT YES, WE SHOULD HAVE
WORKED AS A BLOG AND WE HAD A
GOOD THING GOING.
>> Tucker: WE DO, WE DO.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU, HOLD ON.
>> Juan: $1 BILLION EVERY DAY.
>> Tucker: BUT TELL ME THIS --
>> Juan: LET'S CLOSE THE
BORDER.
>> Tucker: SO WHY IS THAT THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT STOPPING
MIGRANTS FROM CENTRAL AMERICA
BEFORE THEY GET TO THE
UNITED STATES?
INSTEAD MEXICO ENCOURAGING THEM
TO COME HERE.
THAT IS NOT THE BEHAVIOR OF AN
ALLY.
THEY ARE NOT HERE LEGALLY.
WE HAVE A PROCESS AND THEY ARE
NOT GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO THAT IS AN ACT OF HOSTILITY
AND YOU CAN LIE ABOUT IT ALL YOU
WANT.
WHY ARE WE PAYING MONEY?
>> Juan: NO, NO, NO DON'T CALL
ME A LIAR, BROTHER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE IMMIGRANTS,
NUMBER ONE INDIVIDUALS COMING
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
THESE ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T YOU STOP
IF THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
WHY DON'T YOU LET THEM STAY IN
MEXICO?
>> Juan: THESE, 50% OF THEM,
JUST A MINUTE, MY FRIEND.
THE MEXICAN NATION HAS BEEN
GIVING THEM VISAS AND THEY CAN
STAY UP TO A YEAR IN THE COUNTRY
OF MEXICO, WORK AND MEXICO?
>> Tucker: WHITE JUST A YEAR?
>> Juan: LEGALLY, MY FRIEND.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, WAIT A
SECOND, WAIT, I'M CONFUSED.
FIRST OF ALL --
NO COMMIT SOUNDS A LITTLE RACIST
TO ME BY THE STANDARDS THAT YOU
HAVE EXPLAINED.
SO YOU HAVE THESE VERY GOOD
PEOPLE, HOLD ON, YOU LET THEM
STAY FOR A YEAR.
WHY NOT LET THEM DO WHAT WE DO,
HOLD ON, WHY NOT LET THEM STAY
FOREVER AND VOTE IN ELECTIONS
BUT REMAIN GUATEMALANS AND
HONDURANS INTO THE SEVENTH
GENERATION AS YOU SAID ABOUT
YOUR OWN PEOPLE COME ABOUT
MEXICAN CITIZENS.
WHY NOT LET THEM DO THAT AND
STAY FOREVER AND ACCOUNT FOR A
THIRD OF YOUR POPULATION AFTER
100 YEARS?
WHY WOULD THAT BE BAD AND WHY
KICK THEM OUT AFTER A YEAR?
>> Juan: THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ESCAPING VIOLENCE.
THEY WERE 250 MILLION PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD MIGRATING,
LOOKING FOR A BETTER LIFE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE CHOSEN
THESE GOOD PEOPLE, THESE ARE NOT
BAD PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: PLEASE ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
I GET IT.
WHY DON'T YOU GET --
SLOW DOWN.
THEY ARE IN MEXICO AND YOU
ALLOWED THEM OVER EUROPE BORDER.
SIMPLE QUESTION, WHY ARE YOU
PICKING THEM OUT?
THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
WORK.
WHY ARE YOU TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THAT?
>> Juan: MEXICO TODAY, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LAST SIX YEARS AND
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, MEXICO
HAS NOW DEPORTED MORE PEOPLE
THAN CENTRAL AMERICA AND THE
UNITED STATES HAS.
THE NUMBERS HAVE DIMINISHED
INTIMATION.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY ARE GOOD
PEOPLE BUT YOU ARE DEPORTING
THEM.
>> Juan: LOOK, THE IMMIGRANTS
IN THE UNITED STATES HAS
DIMINISHED AND LESS AND LESS
PEOPLE GOING IN.
AND BOTH THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF TIME
AND I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THESE GREAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
DEPORTED BY MEXICO.
MEXICO IS A HOSTILE POWER TO
UNDERMINE OUR COUNTRY AND
SOVEREIGNTY.
>> Juan: IF YOU WILL ALLOW
ME --
>> Tucker: IF IT IS SHORT.
>> Juan: ONE LAST THING,
>> Tucker: VERY QUICK.
>> Juan: BEING TESTED TODAY IN
THE UNITED STATES AND MEXICO HOW
WE WILL CREATE OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS IN THE STATE OF --
WE ARE GOING TO DO THE RIGHT